el cierre de su gira por latinoamérica
la presidenta de la comisión europea
Úrsula bonderlayen visita México y se
reúne con el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador en Palacio Nacional se
espera que la jefa del órgano ejecutivo
comunitario y el mandatario mexicano
aborden algunos de los proyectos que
comprende la iniciativa europea global
Gateway y que consiste en temas como
energías limpias y la conectividad
digital concretamente en el caso de
México podrían abordar el plan Sonora
que es esta estrategia del gobierno
mexicano en el norte del país para la
generación de energía renovables a
partir de plantas fotovoltaicas a raíz
del aumento de los compromisos de México
con el acuerdo de París la Unión Europea
se ha manifestado dispuesta a realizar
inversiones que respeten el medio
ambiente y a las comunidades locales
otro tema que es previsible que aborden
es el acuerdo global que está en vigor
entre México y la Unión Europea y que no
nada más tiene que ver con relaciones
comerciales sino también con cooperación
y diálogo político pero que Data de 1997
Y actualmente está en fase final de
modernización Esta visita de Úrsula
bonder Lion es previa a la Cumbre de la
Unión Europea y la celac que tendrá
lugar en Bruselas en julio próximo